do you remember that moment when you
found out you got it for the first time
I want to hear about Euros too all right
okay go ahead we will trade okay but my
this one is I find I thought it was
quite epic because I was a kid you know
I already knew what I wanted so in in
the Summers my parents live in Greenwich
Connecticut so not a long commute to New
York City I was able to get a waitering
job I met waiters who had commercial
agents I got with a commercial agent
started going out for commercials in the
summer
and so I went up for all these you know
National commercials for you know just
an All-American kid I just wasn't I
wasn't getting the All-American roles
you know I wasn't even getting close
call backs and a buddy of mine who would
book a bunch of these he's like dude you
know you got to work the the Latin angle
got to work that Latino I go and I go
yeah you know they're going to send me
to some you know Spanish-speaking ones
he goes yeah dude Andy because whatever
you do you know you've seen those things
they're really like sort of exuberant
they're just really it's because you
just many just go for it I go really he
goes yeah man just go for it so I went
up for the zest commercial and I'm just
fully clean you're not fully clean until
your zest fully clean okay so try doing
that in Spanish and so can you do it
yeah yeah
so so that was the copy and it was like
I remember like going in there getting
this copy and there's like 400 dudes
that signed up before me I'm like oh my
God and then I I had my friend in my
head saying no you gotta you gotta I had
like this awful like cliched Moment In
The Mirror outside you know in in the in
the uh in the bathroom or the outside
the casting office now okay need to go
for this and you're gonna go for it
you're gonna go for and I did and I went
for it and I got in there and I go
and the cash director goes great give me
more
so I like I just kept amping it up
that's amazing so I went home I booked
the job I was I was like 19. it was I
was gonna get my sag card I was over the
moon I was like jumping up and down I
got the clothes
I get to this set and I remember meeting
the director and he goes to me hey do
you remember what you did in the
audition I go yeah he goes don't do that
why I was like why he goes don't do that
I go okay we're not going to do that
obviously they just hired me for my look
or my you know I don't know but it was
in Spanish it wasn't Spanish I just had
to do it so you just did it very calm
down I brought it down a few notches but
it was to me I I hit the lottery you
know and it ran for a while it ran ran
for enough and it didn't pay much the
the Spanish ones but who cares man it
was exactly it was like it's more than I
was waking it making as a waiter and it
was my sad card and I was 19 and that
was beautiful